Curious how good your eyesight is?
Take a look at this Image Who do you see?
If you're at a normal viewing distance from the screen and have decent eyesight you should be seeing Albert Einstein.
However if you see Marilyn Monroe you may want to consider wearing glasses or contacts.
Wearing your glasses right now? Try taking them off and the image may change or if you're near somebody else ask them what they see,
the effect can actually be seen by anyone if we change the distance or size of the picture.
If it's far away you're more likely to see Marilyn Monroe as our eyes only pick up the broader strokes of an image from a distance
but as you come closer to the image you see the finer details of Einstein
We promise we haven't changed anything digitally, in fact  pause this video now and try walking away from your computer screen
chances are the image will change and at a different distance than your friends because our eyes are all slightly different.
The further away you can stand and still see Einstein the better your eyes likely are.
You can achieve the same effect by squinting your eyes to blur the photo.
So what's going on? Well this image is an example of a hybrid image
whereby a low spatial frequency of one picture is combined
with a high spatial frequency of another but
depending on how well you're able to focus or pick up
contrast your eye will only pick out certain details
Up close we're generally able to see fine details like Eintein's moustache
and wrinkles but as the distance increases
or if your vision is poor and thus creates a more blurred image in the first place
your ability to pick up details fades away instead you only see the general features like
the shape of a mouth, nose and hair
making it seem like Marilyn Monroe.
Love tricking your brain with illusions? We've put together a playlist of our favorite
ones that you can watch by clicking the screen
Don't forget to follow us on facebook, instagram and twitter
and subscribe for more weekly science videos.